Nice to meet you, my name is Kotokoto Iwanaga. Thank you for your
help this time. I'm not
talking about whether you're a princess or something, but if you're a monster, unfortunately only people who have parents and a family register have a prosthetic right eye and a left leg.
[Music]
And this is
Kento Sakuragawa, who will be helping me. Thank you very much.
This is normal.
[Music] I've been
waiting for you. And if Claude is with you, it will be
Benkei.  Naginata: I feel like I'm on a big boat now, and
before that, don't reveal
your true identity to people for no reason.
Luckily, you're not the kind of person who spreads things around, so I'm sorry, but I
felt like this person would be fine.  Also, when
Taizan announced that my cat was talking, people
around him thought that his obscurity had progressed,
but I wondered if it would be a big deal. He
could use that trick, but he wouldn't use it. Who's feeling adventurous?